she is the first author to become a
billionaire there are not many authors
who keep putting out books in a series
that can sell 10 12 15 million copies on
the first day of publication her
imagination has resonated with children
and adults and changed every industry it
touched Harry Potter itself was as big
as as a small publishing company Harry
Potter is the gold standard it is the
biggest movie franchise of all time but
JK Rowling's fairy tale success was born
out of struggle and heartbreak I was
jobless a lone parent I was the biggest
failure I knew with a storybook ending
chapter one
at the center of the most financially
successful story in the history of
fiction Harry Potter is the original and
determined Joanne Rowling she sold
something like 400 million copies of
series books in the United States and
she got a billion kids reading for five
six hundred page tomes in an era where
kids were not reading books at all
probably over ten billion dollars in
overall revenue generated this is an
absolute amazing franchise that I think
we won't see again Harry Potter's
popularity thrust rolling into the
unfamiliar world of celebrity after
being hounded by paparazzi she now
limits access to her private life and
declined to participate in this story
Joanne Rowling was born in 1965 and
Gloucestershire England actor Jim Dale
Rowling's choice of narrator for the
Harry Potter audiobooks in the United
States knew those rural villages well
there were no rich people living in in
those small towns
everybody was working-class you would go
into the houses and see the same
wallpaper that you had because there was
only one wallpaper shop in the town
there was only one co-op store and so
you'd see the same dress that your
mother was wearing was being worn by two
or three other women so it's that kind
of environment Rowling's literary
ambitions were recognized at an early
age she completed her first book named
rabbit when she was six melissa Anneli
interviewed Rowling for her book Harry a
history it was about a rabbit who gets
sick and this is with all his other
animal bunnies and apparently when she
when she finished it she brought up to
her mother and said and sort of had this
attitude of well publish it doesn't it
get made a book now but underneath the
confidence was in security as Rowling
admitted on Oprah I was
not the world's most secure person um I
wasn't someone with an enormous amount
in fact I'd say I was someone with not
much self belief at all and yet and
there's one thing in my life I believed
that was the one thing in my life I felt
I can tell a story her story was shaped
in tussle a small village in
Gloucestershire County Tania saga'
chiyan worked closely with rolling as a
producer on the first for Harry Potter
films she had both a microscopic and a
microcosmic view of Hogwarts in the
Harry Potter universe she'd grown up in
the West Country near the Forester Dean
where I'd spend a lot of my childhood so
lots of points of reference that we had
in common
everything JK wrote about in her books
you know is a description of something
somewhere in England it has to be we do
have the fantastic old castles we do
have those wonderful ancient buildings
we do have those woods you can recognize
almost by her description of a place
that you know of nor somewhere around
the area where she lived in 1980 her
mother was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis a tragic event for the family
but it didn't divert Rowling from her
passion for fiction in school or later
in college Joe was a classics major at
Exeter so everything comes from there
her classical education is all over the
Harry Potter books the Greek myths the
Christian allegories after college
Rowling paid her rent by working at
Amnesty International in London writing
stories on her lunch hour
then in 1990 on a train to London she
had an idea that would change her life
the Train stalled literally into her
head came boy wizard doesn't know he's a
wizard goes to wizard school and because
she didn't have a pen she had to sit and
just think for hours and while this
train was stalled and it all started she
started naming the school she started
thinking of the teachers all that sort
of started forming in Harry Potter and
me she explains what a life-altering
moment this was but incredibly in lated
feeling you get when you've just met
someone with whom you might eventually
fall in love the whole of the Harry
world was her passion the extent to
which this encyclopedic vivid mine knew
what was going to be behind a door that
you didn't even know existed it was
amazing really only six months later she
received heartbreaking news her mother
had passed away from multiple sclerosis
Rowling opened up about her loss for the
BBC I started writing Harry six months
before she died which is that's
obviously a real regret because I never
told her I was even writing it so she
never knew anything about Harry Potter
at all
Joe's mother's death affected everything
about her writing every every last page
of Harry Potter it changed her views on
love and death and what it means when
somebody leaves us and the effect it has
on our lives her focus on the boy wizard
intensified and she was eventually fired
from several jobs for writing instead of
working it was a bleak time for the
unemployed author Rowling decided to
leave England altogether
Joanne Rowling left England to make a
fresh start in porto portugal she got a
job as a teacher while she continued
writing Rowling married a local TV
journalist and within a year had a
daughter
but after what she described as a short
and catastrophic marriage she moved to
Edinburgh Scotland to be near her sister
I think she felt a bit of a failure
because she was poor because she was
very well educated but hadn't found a
positive career yet she tried to get
teaching jobs and work was not
consistent and so she had to go on on
public assistance it was hand to mouth
day to day the absolute subsistence
level of poverty it's not glamorous and
it's not romantic but it did help drive
that book into production Rowling said
that rock-bottom became the solid
foundation to rebuild her life and she
continued to write in the warmth of a
cafe while her daughter napped by her
side and when she had first three
chapters that she thought that she was
happy with she sent it off to an agent
it was rejected in 1995 she sent three
chapters to the Chris Lytle agency there
it got the usual treatment for an
unknown author as little noted on 60
minutes these things can sit in a pile
for ages you know the clear net they'd
known as the slush pile and just by
chance
two days afterwards picked up this pile
and went off to a lunch because somebody
was turning up late and inside I started
reading about Harry Potter and you know
my toast my toes killed but twelve
publishers turned it down nobody wanted
it because at the time it was very non
politically correct to have boarding
schools it was two times as long as any
children's book had a right to be it had
this owners title Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone you know it was all
the things that publishing at the time
said they said books said books
shouldn't be and so he couldn't sell it
the book finally found its way to a new
children's imprint called
Bloomsbury Porter Bibb is a media
analyst and former publisher the CEOs
daughter who read the first two chapters
and came back to her father and said she
wanted to read more that's part of the
beauty of the book publishing business
it goes to a great extent on gut feeling
in 1996 six years after she began
writing Harry Potter
Bloomsbury offered her $4,000 for the
book it wasn't much as deals go but for
Rowling it was magic that moment when he
told me that Bloomsbury wanted to take
the book second only to the birth of my
daughter was happiest moment of my life
but there was a catch to try and improve
its marketability Bloomsbury wanted her
to change her pen name to something
gender-neutral as little pointed out on
60 minutes condition they boys don't
like to read books written by by girls
girls read books written by anybody but
girl boys have this sort of peculiar
sort of sex this thing joanne borrowed a
middle initial from her grandmother
Kathleen and became JK Rowling at the
1997 bolonia Book Fair word-of-mouth was
building Arthur a levine vice-president
of scholastic
had flown there looking for something
special I wanted to find books that were
not just trendy or you know popular of
the moment but that would be really
loved by kids
and would be their favorite books
Michael Jacobs was the senior VP of
scholastic
trade division at the time this
certainly was a book that was had bill
had a lot of buzz going around at
bologna and I think yes it was pretty
evident I think to Arthur that the book
had potential to be a series but the
first book itself was extraordinary just
as a standalone Lavigne offered an
unprecedented 105 thousand dollars for
American rights to the first Harry
Potter book when Joe got the call from
Christopher little that said you know
your books been sold for 105
dollars in America she said that she was
very scared for the first time it was
very overwhelming should be honest life
had battered me around so much of the
penis to use that when you start
receiving good news you're quite
mistrustful the good news continued in
1997 the book was published in the UK
and it was a hit the first round of
schoolyard Potterheads was born
Joanne Rowling's second book was already
in the works after the top dollar sale
of the first Harry Potter to scholastic
she felt enormous pressure to continue
the momentum after the American sale it
was a big story in England because now
an unknown British author has sold their
first book in America which is the you
know Holy Grail as opposed to the
English market it's five or six times
bigger
it was penniless author rags to riches
tale the US publishers were hoping Harry
Potter which strike literary gold we
knew we had something special on her
hands you know you have a sort of
lightning in a bottle at certain point
in time we knew that fairly early on so
our approach really was to publish it as
a blockbuster we had a basically a kind
of a SWAT team war room
that's clastic that met every week about
Harry Potter scholastic decided to take
an interactive approach to marketing the
book we did that's reading copies of the
book birth to a select number of people
got it into their hands I think some
actually got to meet Jo Rowling before
the book was even published so you know
we created a buzz that way but then once
the book began to sell it you know it
just sort of took off like wildfire
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
sold over 800,000 copies in 10 months
and spent more than a year on the New
York Times bestseller list as the second
installment hit United States stores in
1999 release of the Potter books became
major events scholastic cast a spell on
the public
they put on extravaganzas with each new
title that came out and had literally
thousands of kids standing outside of
bookstores mostly in costume in the
middle of the night waiting to get the
copies the logistics of laying 10
million or 11 million copies of the book
down in one day where we're difficult as
you can well imagine in transporting the
books making sure they were secured and
locked down making sure that books
didn't get into anybody's hands before
they got in everyone's hands the sales
when each book recently hired the first
printings became a much much bigger the
one dark cloud that cast a shadow on the
growing phenomenon were protests from
conservative religious groups who saw
evil in the mystical storylines they
accused Rowling of promoting witchcraft
and the occult and burned her books even
though Harry Potter just taken the Lord
by storm
witchcraft is not fictional and it is
not fantasy
witchcraft is real that your devil is
real
if people think that witchcraft should
not be in books for children per se and
then there's really no point in engaging
in the debate cuz a lot of classic
children's books are going to be right
off the library shelves in an instant
Wizard of Oz even Cardinal Joseph
Ratzinger now Pope Benedict the
sixteenth had his own reservations and
the American Library Association listed
Rowling's as the number one most
challenged text in the United States but
the backlash didn't affect sales at all
Harry Potter's continual reign over the
New York Times bestseller list
ultimately forced the paper to add a
whole separate children's category sure
our competitors were happier that they
may have been more slots on the
bestseller list because we were probably
would have dominated the top 5 with the
first five books and blocked everyone
else out even audiobook sales were
breaking records and enchanting fans as
narrator Jim dale discovered at a live
reading in new york a count of four
hundred children and mothers turned up
and one child suddenly yelled out you've
left a sentence out as if it was the
biggest mistake and the mother said i do
apologize but he's memorized the whole
book and from the audience i heard other
little voices calling up so have I so if
I
international distributors snatched up
the rights to translate the books and
Harry Potter became a worldwide
sensation demand became so intense that
there was a danger of the Harry Potter
brand spiraling out of control
we had supermarkets and convenience
stores and gas stations and sort of
other retailers whose all of a sudden
wanted Harry Potter books so that they
could drive traffic almost as a lost
leader for their particular business
JK Rowling turned down hundreds of
licensing offers from the likes of Sony
Microsoft and Boeing but remained
fiercely loyal to her vision as she
shared here on 60 minutes if people
could see the kind of office I've had to
use Harry in advertising and publicity
and all sorts of ridiculous frankly
things and I've said no to absolutely
all of them but there was one offer she
couldn't refuse from Hollywood and one
studio was about to discover that Harry
Potter might just work miracles I was
working for a new production company for
David Heyman who'd said to me go and
find me something for the studio well I
read an article in a newspaper that said
that someone had written the first in a
seven series book about a little boy who
goes to boarding school and discovers
he's a wizard so when I went and met her
agent and tried to convince him to let
us buy it we were coming as Warner
Brothers
halda Garabedian is president of the box
office division of hollywood.com
i paid for warner brothers to get the
Harry Potter franchise was a mission
I mean Warner Brothers had had great
success with the Batman franchise with
the Matrix franchise and he they were
determined to do it and I think that's
why they gave JK Rowling such latitude
in terms of her control over this
process and over the series of films our
first meeting with JK Rowling was over
lunch actually David Heyman and I had
told her a little bit about what we
wanted to do with the film and she sat
down with us and we tried desperately
hard to impress her and she of course
didn't need to impress us cuz she would
he have done
JK Rowling was paid reportedly two
million dollars by Warner Brothers for
the rights to those first four films
there are not many authors who keep
putting out books in a series that can
sell 10 12 15 million copies on the
first day of publication that gave her a
lot of leverage that leverage allowed
her to demand that the film be shot in
Britain with an all British cast and
that she would have a role in choosing
both the actors and directors top
directors clamored for admission to
Rowland's imaginary world well I know
that Steven Spielberg was approached to
direct the first Harry Potter film and
he actually wanted to do it as an
animated film but that didn't come to
pass and so Chris Columbus stepped in
producer David Heyman introduced the
hand-picked cast in a Warner Brothers
video versus choice of three wonderful
British actors for the leading roles
shows how well he understands the spirit
of these books I think her primary
concern about a film being made of her
vision was that we were true and
faithful to the books I think she had
really worked incredibly hard and
constructing characters in a story that
she believed in and what she didn't want
to see was that being chopped up and
misinterpreted what
right absent the biggest challenge of
bringing JK Rowling's vision to the
screen was that by the time we were
filming it everybody had read it
could you ever imagine that would be
like this
oh never in a million years I mean this
was the last thing I expected the first
Harry Potter film hit movie screens in
November 2001 once again the boy wizard
worked wonders the film was a
record-breaking hit it opened ninety
point three million dollars which turned
out to be the biggest opening weekend of
that year the film went on to earn three
hundred and seventeen million dollars
which was the biggest earner
domestically at the box office in 2001
Rowling not only retained creative
control she negotiated an undisclosed
percentage of the movie and licensing
profits more important she was happy
with the final product
I guess my abiding memory of her
reaction to the completed films was we
did it it's all right we didn't let her
down
2001 was also the year Joanne Rowling
happily married her second husband dr.
Neil Michael Murray and the Harry Potter
movies continued to be blockbusters
every Harry Potter movie has opened at
number one it has a perfect opening
weekend track record we're talking about
a decade we're talking about seven films
at the at Racal box office for the seven
Harry Potter films and this doesn't even
include part two of Deathly Hallows is
six point four billion dollars that
doesn't even include home video product
tie-ins any kind of soundtrack sales
anything else it's the biggest movie
franchise of all time
Roli also receives a cut of Mattel's 200
million dollar-plus revenues in Harry
Potter toys and her merchandising Empire
continues to expand it's hard to think
of something that didn't at one point or
another have a Harry Potter image
attached to it whether it's in the games
business the toys even clothing business
its humongously successful in 2010 Harry
Potter took claim of its own theme park
at Universal Studios in Orlando named
the Wizarding World of Harry Potter and
once again Rowling's personal stamp was
on everything from the snow on the roof
to the taste of the butterbeer they
actually pack up the ingredients went up
to Edinburgh made it and presented it to
her and she tasted them all and said
that one that one is exactly butterbeer
she's had two more children and now
makes her home on a pastoral estate in
northern Scotland and five years after
the last Potter book Rowling published a
new novel for adults I have gone from
dragons and unicorns and all the fun
that's involved in writing that to a
book that's intensely personal that
expresses a lot of my reality the Casual
Vacancy didn't have the same magic with
critics but it still hit number one on
the bestsellers lists Rowling has
redefined success in the literary world
her net worth is estimated to be near 1
billion dollars making her among the
richest women in the world
she has become a wonderfully elevated
brand in terms of stature and ethics and
the way that she conducts herself her
generosity extends to charities that
include aid to single-parent children
the poor and to multiple sclerosis
research for 17 years
Rowling lived and breathed Harry Potter
her story much like his was marked by
overcoming dreadful challenges on the
way to extraordinary success as she told
the Harvard graduating class in 2008 the
knowledge that you have emerged wiser
and stronger from setbacks means that
you are ever after secure in your
ability to survive you will never truly
know yourself or the strength of your
relationships until both have been
tested by adversity such knowledge is a
true gift for all that it is painfully
won and it has been worth more than any
qualification I ever earned